In general it's easy to use power divided by root rather than to expand the
factors of a variable. But not all powers are evenly divisible by a root. We
know 3 doesn't divide evenly into 14. We could rewrite x to the 14th as x to
the 12th times x squared. We use our product tool to split this up into two
separate cube roots. And since we know that cube root of x to the 12 is equal
to x to the 4th, this would be our final answer. An easier way to get to this
more quickly is to use power divided by root and to look at the remainder. We
know this radical can be written as x to the 14 divided by 3. So when I divide
the power by the root, I get 14 divide 3, which equals 4 remainder 2. Notice
that the 4 appears as the exponent of our factor outside of the radical,
whereas the remainder 2, is the power inside of the radical. So, using this
ideal of the remainder, I want you to see if you can simplify this radical. Use
the idea of power divided by root to figure out what would be on the outside of
the radical and what would stay on the inside. When you think you have it put
your answer here.